[Music]
the tough economy inflation job Cuts
have workers looking to expand their
careers and income this new year so
which careers are considered red hot and
what's the outlook for students who are
graduating college this spring the
answer in today's eight on your side
according to the world economic Forum
emerging jobs are in the digital space
data science
AI
digital marketing these are the kinds of
roles that are really really growing
according to Microsoft more than a
hundred million jobs will be in these
fields by 2025. Betty vanderbosch is the
CEO of a popular online education
platform called Coursera she's
monitoring a growing Trend with job
relevant degrees that shows more people
are looking for classes and
certifications in business and Tech and
data science over other career paths
some people might want to be an
information technology specialist
someone else might want to be a digital
marketer someone else wanted might want
to do ux design and somebody might want
to do project management reports from
glassdorin indeed indicate this year
we'll see employers Vine for top talent
to fill a tight labor market and numbers
from the National Association of
colleges and employers show the number
of graduates hired will sit about 15
percent higher than last year in what's
considered a very good to excellent job
market for those who want to feel out a
potential career in any of these fields
vanderbosch says you can start by
learning some of the skills online one
really exciting trend is that companies
are starting to recognize the value of
Industry micro credentials companies
like IBM meta Google and Intuit offer
these certificates on Corsair and
companies are recognizing their value